the FDA's approval is incredibly
disappointing the approval was
irresponsible and flawed if these GMO
salmon escaped they could cause
devastating environmental harm to wild
salmon populations they're more
susceptible to disease and deformities
they have potential health problems
I understand that we eat stuff that are
genetically modified all the time but
like why not keep what we have and keep
it natural I think that's okay I would
eat an eel so I can I eat an eel and a
salmon together more than 60 grocery
retail chains have already committed to
not selling GMO salmon despite the fact
that the FDA has now approved it and
consumers have said they won't eat it